moi j'entends ce que dit gilles
j'entends ce que dit guillaume c'est des
journalistes ils sont dans le métier et
c'est tard etc moi je trouve ça
dégueulasse oh ça honteux les
documentaires comme ça tf1 de 20 heures
on te sort des images d'une petit
mensonge je pense aux parents je pense à
la famille tuvache même du mal à
respirer si si on l'avait fait ça à ma
fille on voit nordahl le land à côté et
j'entendais présumé sans hymne aux
innocents elle est là et dans sa voiture
on a trouvé du sang dans sa voiture mais
moi j'ai du mal à dire présumé innocent
c'est qui alors elle était dans sa
voiture on n'a plus jamais revu la
petite moi je dis honte à tf1 ils ont
des enfants à tf1 le mais les mecs qui
sont dans les bureaux quand ils font les
relais documentaire quand ils disent ça
on va le mettre à l'antenne il on dégote
ces gens-là guillaumie dit ouais moi
c'est comme ça mais peut-être dieu n'a
pas d'enfant le jour où tu auras des
enfants si on touche à ta fille comme ça
et que tu vois tf1 le 20 heures toute ta
famille tous que ça engendre on va par
là peut-être que vous allez faire quand
on mettra vos enfants au 20 heures elle
est partie d'affilée on la reverra plus
on sait finir elle est morte wave ouvrez
les yeux faut arrêter c'est que l'on
joue comme ça c'est de la merde
mais cette rencontre l'histoire oui mais
je comprends ce que tu n'es pas dans
l'émotionnel à saint-marc démago sont là
font enlever toutes les émissions où
j'ai fini là je savais me mais alors il
ya 21 janvier sont comme les jt on parle
d'affaires fait qu'il était de faire cet
honneur de deux de mes excuse moi de 31
janvier le procès commence là maintenant
tu passes un truc comme si tous les
médias font ça ne joue pas tous les
atouts ne devrait pas faire juste rémois
là là là effectivement il ya l'émotion
c'est de la barbarie c'est au delà du
supportable on est d'aller mais
simplement pour toutes les affaires de
faits divers dont on parle régulièrement
ici tu pourrais dire la même chose
ne sont pas finis il ya une tradition
française qui est de par les défis sont
faits divers parce que les gens sont
passionnés mais pas forcément au centre
angevin jeunes gens qui lisent mettez
vous à la place des familles oui il
quand tu es dans le nouveau détective
quand tu es dans des trucs faites entrer
l'accusé à 23h quand tu es dans des
programmes alliant la vessie et
peut-être tu décide d'y aller regarder
ce programme là sur des faits divers sur
des meurtres personne décide le 20h ya
marqué le vainqueur moi je veux pas que
ce torchon là dans mon 20 heures je
passais de torchon là dans mon 20 heures
mon batteur tu me donnes de
l'information tu me fais pas du
voyeurisme avec une gamine qui a été
lâchement assassinés par un peu je vais
je vais insulter c'est pas la peine je
fais insulter c'est quoi c'est quoi ces
trucs là après je vous comprends votre
position vous êtes journaliste et bien
on voit l'un vendu un documentaire et
les gens ils vont venir et vous regardez
il ya des endroits pour faire ça moi je
procède 31 janvier la petite malice on
la voit dans la voiture à prendre la
voie plus jamais pensé à la famille deux
minutes et et mettez vous dans des rôles
de parents et de pair si je pète un
câble en fait ça
mais j'entends mais là c'est un sujet du
20 heures c'est que tout le monde a
envie de connaître plus on l'a fait avec
d'autres affaires mais tu as raison mais
tu as raison effectivement c'est une
petite fille c'est ouais t'as raison
doute bien que c'est lui qui a qui
voient là il est présumé innocent selon
le tour c'est tout ce qui n'est pas
innocent ça c'est un fait ma taille pour
le coup ils font leur métier ils ont un
scoop il ne diffuse le composent mais
voilà mathieu
par rapport à la sensée tf1 le 20 heures
personne vous avoue l'excusé avant pour
dire bonjour ne fait pas c'est que dans
les émissions de télévision
par dont celles activées avec l'émotion
de santé mentale et je comprends
parfaitement mais le journaliste que
c'est pas ça lasse et de l'enquète il
avait un scoop énorme s'écoulerait
constitution alors bien sûr
effectivement c'est horrible mais là
c'est justement ce qui permet de voir la
barbarie c'est ce qui permet d'avancer
aussi et toutes ces affaires sont au
régent attendent aval gilles muller
toutes ces affaires sont horribles alors
bien sûr que c'est horrible pour une
personne mais c'est un scoop énorme pour
tf1 qui montre la barbarie l'histoire
est évidemment qui fait le diffuser
évidemment tu te trompes le savent a été
de me dire nordahl hollandais il est
coupable parce qu'on a trouvé ça en plus
ça c'est un scoop mais ont
raté un truc qu'on a déjà qu'on connaît
déjà qu'on a déjà vu me faire voir une
photo d'une fille aurait raconté c'est
normal vu la voiture ya zéro ce couple
adam même votre mot le scoop le scoop
pour une gamine qui a été qu était
assassiné le scoop arrêter les mais qu
on redescend et on se remet les choses
en place y'a pas de scoop à faire là
dedans y'a pas de scoop à faire avec une
gamine qui est assassiné par un par un
prédateur qui va finir sa vie en fait
que sept mètres dans ses comptes à
montre bien que raconter les choses et
les voir c'est différent la barbarie tu
viens de l'avoir ici ce que fait tf1
c'est bien et c'est ce qu'il fallait est
ce que c'est la menace est très dure et
ça donne 20 heures mais bien sûr c'est
la période des fêtes à 14h30 c'est là
qu'il fallait faire pour gagner je suis
désolé
mais parce que c'est là parce que c'est
de l'information c'est parce que c'est
le moment l'information le jt de 20
heures c'est toujours des moments
malheureusement quand tu pourras jt de
20 heures raymond 90% c'est des
mauvaises nouvelles et à la fin c'est
vider par la météo c'est ça le jt de 20h
a été dénoncé la barbarie les erreurs du
monde d'en prendre conscience c'est ça
et c'est le rôle des journalistes est
même au 31 janvier la le procès commence
le 31 janvier il est présumé innocent si
vous voulez pour les gens et pour la
justice parce que y'a la justice en
france maintenant la dernière fois qu'on
l'a vu c'est avec lui le sens qu'on a
trouvées dans le coffre celle sans
malice wallace top ya pas à chercher ce
coup plus loin on laisse faire la
justice est si vous voulez faire des
enquêtes table si tu voulais pas qu'ils
voulaient faire c'est celui qui est
capable ça n'engage que moi ça n'engage
que mes propos que la tunisie mais ça
n'engage que lui je m'en fous ça
n'engage que moi c'est moi je dis ce que
je pense maintenant maintenant vous
voulez faire des reportages pas de
problème laisser faire le procès un
petit peu laissé avancer le procès et
après si vous voulez on fait des faites
entrer l'accusé on fait plein de trucs
si vous voulez c'est ce que je ressens
moi en tant que père on aurait fait ça
ma fille tf1 tf1 passe un truc comme ça
sur ma fille je sais même pas ce que je
fais je sais même pas si je vais pas en
bas de chez tf1 pour faire une bêtise
c'est le en tant que père je parle près
on peut avoir de débattre en 30 heures
on sera jamais d'accord